All right. Our penultimate question on regular expressions.
Which of the following sentences are true? Check all that apply.
Any regular expression written using + could be rewritten without +
but match exactly the same set of strings.
There is no regular expression that catches all strings that look like a^n.
Remember this exponentiation here means copies so this would be a, aa, aaa.
There's no regular expression that gets that whole infinite set.
Here, there's no regular expression for a^n b^n,
so this would be ab, aabb, aaabbb
and then down here every regular expression has an associated finite state machine
that recognizes the same strings.